one of the most rewarding things about
working in Madagascar is we had a chance
to work with a lot of the young Malagasy
scientists these are grad students
working towards getting their PhDs and
we were able to help them do the
research which has become some of the
building block research for learning
more and more about lemurs we needed
these people desperately because we
didn't just need information you know we
needed good information Nani is my
student
she's been here looking at the injury
and then suddenly on August 23rd she had
a surprise though the baby was born here
in the street known in history and the
epoch the truth is the first data of an
infant baby right here thank you nothing
that's a girl so we can think I max for
this data as a first data and an infant
born in the injury group that's it's
just amazing
so we just got this really incredible
shot because it's an injury here who
gave birth 13 days ago none of America
captivity so I don't think anybody's
seen a 13 day old injury before and we
are on film it's fantastic you can never
have done it without Nani thanking Hani
one of the things that makes me
optimistic about lemurs is the young
scientists that have been trained in the
last two decades they care about these
animals it's wonderful to see
you